كنا اقرب وقت الى ال سكان قبل بضعه اشهر
قدمتم اولوا حاط الى مجلس الامن حول
السودان من الخرطوم واليوم والمره الاولى
على الاطلاق احط مجلس الامن من الاراضي
الليبيه وفي ابريل ايضا الملاحظات حول
اسلوب عملنا وحددنا اليوم مجلس الامن في
نيويورك
توينتي
الى دول مختلفه وجمعنا الادله واليوم ايضا
اعلنته الى مجلس الامن
في ليبيا كما ركزت ايضا
يشعرون مستمر
اذا ما استمر هذا الفصل بيننا وبين الشعوب
الذين من المفترض ان يوفر لهم القانون
العداله واللي نظمنا ان ما حصل لهم
ومواجهوه يجب ان يحقق فيه بالشكل المناسب
والا فسيكون هنالك انعدام او تاكل للثقه
والذي سيؤثر على المحكمه الجنائيه الدوليه
والمجتمع المدني والدول والشركات ويجب ان
يتخلص من فكره ان هذه مشكله الطرف الاخر
هي ليست كذلك هي مشكله المشتركه حاليا
المشاهدون شاشه التلفزيون
والمشاكل كثيره في نسيج الاجتماعي التي
تؤثر على العديد من الدول العالم واذا ما
قلنا منها المتحده ومشكله المحكمه تجاري
ومشكلتكم فسوف نستمر
علينا جميعا
واضح لكن
نبقى قليلا في الشان الليبي تحديدا هناك
من يرى ان الضغوط مستمره على المحكمه اصلا
للنظر فقط في قضايا على علاقه بنظام معمر
القذافي في حين انه البيليشات على الارض
في ليبيا سواء كانت التي ادعت الاسلاميه
او غيرها ارتكبت جرائم كثيره ربما اكثر
حتى من النظام القذافي كيف تردون على هذا
الموجوده في المجال العامه
ليس له علاقه
2011 ونظام القديم بل له علاقه
بانشاطات المعروفه
كان علينا ان نسحبه تلك المذكره اعلنت عن
ذلك اليوم